[Musique]
votre avis comme on aimera en l'an 2000
je pense que ça sera
- entiché de de frein dieu à l'éducation
qu'on a reçue à lille
je pense que les rapports soient
beaucoup plus vivre à peut-être un
retour
oui un certain romantisme peut-être la
sexualité va retourner va essayer de
faire la jonction avec avec ce qui se
passe dans la tête aussi la mort
physique
la pornographie je pense que ça réglera
pas ce que tu fais de l'évolution
les gens dans le puits des zones
et cet aspect là pour l'érotisme tout
pas si ça continue ça doit avoir nom du
peuple sera plus on gâche tout tous les
sentiments sont rares chez tout et
d'alice et l'animalité maintenant on
était simple bipèdes c'est tout rien de
plus mais qu'est ce qui vous fait dire
ça parce que y'a qu'à voir le gros
porteur et john on couche on va à 13 ans
14 ans après l' importance si vous
trouvez ça vaut va voir ça qui est
l'amour
costaud dans la vie on veut penser à la
tempe
il y aura toujours des gens qui voudront
avoir la robe blanche le mariage c'est à
mon avis n'apporte rien d'être mariée si
c'est pour dans trois mois plus en
tentant de se poser hier une nouvelle
loi qui viennent peu de temps pour au
cas où bon mais le père puisse pas
claqué la porte et dire salut c'est pas
mon enfant et je te donne rien tu te
débrouilles un accord j'espère que ce
sera de mieux en mieux que ce sera
l'épanouissement baisse qui démarre en
ce moment c'est à dire la liberté
il y en aura pas un seul petit ami je
crois qu'on aura beaucoup pour moi ce
sera peut être un jour partira en europe
par exemple le même titre à partir en
reste où tu voudras à les spams à
florence moment se dira salut je reviens
dans trois semaines on sera plus à nous
alors c'est ça qui ont partout assez on
a toujours l'instinct jaloux quand même
la liberté ça amène quelques voix la
révolution
mais révolution ça veut dire changement
révolutionner c'est au sens propre c'est
tout retourné
mais dans l'amour aussi tout ce retour
n'aura plus qui est l'homme était la
fille
vous avez regardé des jeunes couples
alors quand mènera aussi que le père
joël rôle de la mère et la mère jouera
le rôle du père quelques fois et que les
femmes et on entre elles les hommes
entre eux pourquoi pas si ça leur plaît
que je pense c'est que l'amour
romantique enfin l'amour le désir
l'attachement total pour quelqu'un
existera toujours ça je crois que
c'est une constante de la nature humaine
mais que peut-être les gens se sentiront
d'en face pourront pas l'amour unique ça
arrive une seule fois vous parler de
l'amour l'amour dans l'amour à baiser
moi il n'y aura pas de l'amour à l'an
2000 ce serait plutôt un ordinateur qui
qui distribuera plus ou moins le mot la
sensation où il la sensation mais seul
et se seraient tous les programmes et
les tirs près
qu'est-ce que vous souhaite enfin après
l'an 2000 à partir de l'an 2000
non non je souhaiterais aller parce
qu'il ya un progrès il ya une évolution
assez rapide dans ce domaine là et que
les gens sont devenus des robots
[Musique]